now the head of one of the world's most
influential companies samsung has been
jailed for corruption
j y lee has been sentenced to two and a
half years in prison by a south korean
court
he was convicted of bribing an associate
of former president park geun-hye
robin mcbride joins us live from seoul
so what actually happens to him now
does this go to appeal
this is a real shock uh many people here
had been expecting that he was going to
avoid going back behind bars and when
the news came in fact the samsung
share price dropped by a couple of
percentage points it has since rebounded
somewhat
since then but it does give you an idea
of just how unexpected this was many
business groups here in south korea
had appealed to the court for leniency
in fact samsung themselves uh
has appealed all along saying that it
needs its boss this is by far the
biggest conglomerate here
in the south korean economy j.y lee is
its de facto head it does not want him
to have him sitting behind bars all of
these charges go back to
2017 when jay wylie was found guilty of
bribery of paying bribes this was all
involved in the collapse of the
government of park geun-hye the
disgraced
president at the time and also a long
time associate of hers choi son sil both
of whom
are now serving long terms in prison now
lee was
found guilty of having paid bribes to
foundations controlled by
choi it was thought as a way of
smoothing the transition of power from
his father who was incapacitated at the
time
to him and himself now he was originally
sentenced to five years he served one
year of that before being released but
the prosecution
has been trying to reimpose a tougher
sentence and that is what has been
achieved this monday he walked into
court
to hear the ruling but was immediately
re-arrested again he is likely to take
this back to the supreme court
but for the moment lee is back behind
bars
with the two and a half years ahead of
him rob mcbride there
thanks so much